okay now I want to believe in the fairy
tale truly I do
I kind handsome prince for with madly in
love with a beautiful Hollywood starlet
and they live happily ever after
but hang on this Hollywood starlet is a
fiercely intelligent independent woman
who's forged a successful career and the
cutthroat world of showbiz
she's a campaigner a charity worker she
says stuff like Trump as a misogynist
Megan Markel is no fluffy Sloan whose
only aim in life is to marry well she's
no way tkt messing around with menial
jobs till her prince decides to propose
she's a woman with a mind of a Rome and
as much as she's melted the heart of
this hardened old hack I fear for her
the parallels with Diana just can't be
ignored until now she and Harry have
hidden from the world enjoying their
cozy cottage in Kensington Palace
but now there's no hiding place the eyes
of the world are upon them every move
every kiss every touch every sideways
glance will be recorded because now the
paparazzi have a new darling and they
will hunt her just like they hunted
Diana the lovely Megan says she knows
what's coming my fear is that she has
absolutely no idea hmm
Carol I think we've actually finally
found a topic on which we have a bit of
agreement because I think what you're
saying is in praise of Megan Markel and
like you I liken in my hair do too and I
found myself in a very counterintuitive
position this week of being quite pro
royal family which not that I've ever
been Antti the royal family but they've
just not been of interest to me really
I've never really related to them before
they haven't felt like a family that in
any way represent someone like me so for
the first time because of Megan Mark I
finally find myself interested in a
royal wedding and I think what you're
saying is true and I think it's really
useful because we do have short memories
to remember what happened to Diana we
all remember what happened to Diana but
we don't talk very often about the way
that she was treated by the press and
the paparazzi and those comments that
her brother made at her funeral about
how she was the most hunted woman on
earth which was so haunting and I think
you're right that it is an issue but
I don't know what the answer is because
you know when you think about the royal
family they play such a symbolic role
that's they're already they're symbolic
they don't play any real political
constitutional role other than a
symbolic one and that works because
people are interested in them I think
she wants and people are interested in
them because they're in the public eye
and we have access to information about
their lives and that's where the
paparazzi come in so if they were to be
private there would kind of be no point
for them that's the dilemma and I don't
I don't know I suppose when I was
watching her the thing that struck me
most of all you know she's incredibly
intelligent
you know she the way she conducted that
interview I thought was a master class
and how to do exactly that you compare
that to previous engagements of you know
of wheels and before that with Diane I
mean that she she was just so cool my
fear is that she she is used to doing
everything the way she wants to do it
this girl speaks out when she wants to
speak out she campaigns in the manner in
which she wants to campaign and my fear
is that now that she's in the firm
everything will change you know she said
something in it there's a fact we've got
it we've got a clip let's watch this
clip did this kind of sums it up for me
I think I can very safely say as naive
as it sounds now having gone through
this learning curve in the past year and
a half I did not have any understanding
of just what it would be like I don't
think either of us did that we both said
that even though we knew that it would
be I tried to I tried I tried to warn I
tried to warn you as much as possible
but I think both of us were totally
surprised by the reaction after the
first five six months of when we had to
ourselves now when you look at that they
actually think they're prepared from
what's coming they think they know
what's coming and they have no idea and
he he says I tried to warn her and they
think they've been bothered in the past
year but they haven't and now the world
spotlight is on them and it will never
be turned down as long as she draws
breath I think she'll be and first of
all props to offer who is now the go-to
person on a royal wedding absolutely
nothing's changed so much more I think
that I think you're both completely
wrong I mean look at it she's a she's a
Hollywood starlet she is extremely
accomplished and she's very vocal and
she was husband but you know let's look
at it realistically what happens to
Hollywood starlets in their first
she's you know it's a succession of
surgeries and then you're phased
off-screen I think she's got exactly the
part she wants and she will play the
part to perfection if you listen to what
she said in in that interview it was
fascinating she's this country she's
going into this country she said boots
on the ground as if she's a taking over
and invading a small country good on her
I think the royal family won't know what
she's not come up against the firm yet
the firm controls everything it all but
destroyed Diana and it's you okay that
was the 1981 let me tell you I think
you're wrong because and and quite right
now has talked about this but it is it
is fantastic that we have a woman who's
already been married who's an American
and who's a mixed-race I don't to bang
on about that but a few years ago this
wouldn't this wouldn't have even been a
consideration within the palace it shows
how the family huh I think the firm is
that I think they've moved on I think
they've regenerated themselves I think
it's fantastic bear in mind this woman
is 36 I think I'm right saying that was
the age at which Princess Diana died
though she's having she's done she was
object she's in a lot of living she's
done a little bit of loving as well
she's a very accomplished actress
I think it's nothing but good and I hear
what you say but she's a lot older she's
a lot wiser and Carol you and I both
know when Fleet Street when Her
Majesty's Prison it's full height of
ugliness we don't have those days
anymore but we do certainly do still
have the paparazzi nip which are not
part of the mainstream media they're not
but they're they're a totally different
but I think because she made such an
incredible impression the other day I
think the hunger for her will never be
will never be just lousy because we must
be you're comparing this accomplished
actress who had this TV show with and
I'd not knock him down up sir
she was a kindergarten teacher I mean
well you say so well I I do struggle to
get majorly excited by the news I mean
who's just saying that you you know
quite excited and all the rest of it I
was doing the news reviews on Tuesday
morning after this was announced and
there was page I'm talking like 10
budget there is souvenir pull out Steve
I mean what an after you doing I would
dismiss me
I miss that good we'll follow that this
is the fever that I'm talking about list
I'm gonna be subjected to this narrow
and to me until this wedding day what is
she wearing where's she going what is a
mom doing what so amazing love it why is
that is it that desire to sweetness like
intimate stuff around these to Diane
she's that giant was a dazzling
combination of royalty and Hollywood and
this girl is gonna be the same when she
came into the firm which you became that
actually the production created this for
the myth of Diana
Dubey and she is she had Hollywood
friends and she had amorous friends and
chefs friends in the fashion world
this girl is exactly the same I mean I
don't know how you don't see what's
gonna happen - I think she's dating us
that she's just being initialized she's
not smart enough to stop people hounding
it you know her life as she knew would
deserve but she'll never be able to go
to the shops again sure they'll be able
to go what she thinks that's what she
wants now I'm distinctly sure I should
Michelle asked a question which is why
do people care so much about all these I
think I understand even though I've not
been interested in the royal family
before because I think when people look
at the royal family they see something
about themselves you know the royal
family represent people sense of
Britishness they represent the part of
people's identity ask a lot of rich
people what it means to be British the
Queen and the royal family will come in
so their arts or somewhere I know
they're German well I mean we all know
that if that's the idea of symbols you
know it's myth making its narrative the
thing that's interesting is not just her
but Harry as well who has behaved
differently to previous senior Royals
and I'm just going to read you bit the
statement he wrote in response to the
media storm when their relationship was
first announced when he said it's not
right that a few months into a
relationship with him that miss Marcal
should be subjected to such a storm he
and this is the Harry NoZe commentators
will say this is the price she has to
pay and that this is all part of the
game he strongly disagrees this is not a
game it's her life and here's and he's
taking her strongest arts leave but
that's not what will happen every I mean
I'm surprised you you're not Kirin
because I would have thought someone of
your age would have would have you'd be
bonded to Harry in the way that young
people are bonded to young people and
you would be excited by it when were you
last on the attack
not in that way because it's two young
people and so I think it's very nice
that they've found love I think is
awesome and I'm very happy for them but
that's where it stops I don't need to
nerve wear her dresses from or what she
used to do or who her best mate was at
school subtracted some of the envying
her no I do think women I am being the
opportunity to become a I don't have to
be called princess hairy biker's weird
so weird we're not making whales could
you get anything because of that someone
with her brain with her intelligence as
the gunner becomes very bored very
quickly with the mundanity of ROI like
everything kind of pay with the
Commonwealth taking remember she said
we've got lots to do everything maybe
because it was a train kids New Zealand